KI erobert die Welt nach dem
sensationellen Start des von Microsoft
gepowerten Chat GPT zieht nun ein
weiterer Tech Gigant nach Gemini von
Google will unsere Welt von Grund auf
verändern nicht nur kreativ wirkende
Texte soll Gemini generieren sondern die
multimodale KI analysiert angeblich
schon selbst komplexe Zusammenhänge und
das quasi mit eigenen
Augen sag mir was du siehst ich sehe wie
du einen Zettel auf den Tisch legst ich
sehe eine geschwungene Linie und
jetzt die Konturen sind weich und
fließend ohne Spitzen und scharfe
Kanten für mich sieht das wie ein Vogel
aus und
jetzt der Vogel schwimmt im Wasser es
hat einen langen Hals und einen Schnabel
eine Ente ja eine Ente ist ein
Wasservogel aus der Familie der anatidae
Enten sind verwandt mit Gänsen und
schwernen die Ente scheint blau zu sein
das ist keine gewöhnliche Farbe für
Enten das Rennen um die
leistungsstärkste KI ist in vollem Gang
staunerde Faszination mischt sich mit
gruseligem Schaudern denn die neue
Technik zeigt auch schon ihr hässliches
Gesicht der geklonte ZDF Moderator der
für eine Geldanlage Werbung
machtestützten anlageplattform die
bereits Millionen von Deutschen Bürgern
zu oder der KI Kanzler der mehr schlecht
als recht zum Verbot der AFD aufruft
Mitbürger meine Regierung wird zum fünft
Todestag von Walter Lüpke am 2 juni 2024
beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht ein Verbot der
Partei Alternative für Deutschland
beantragen Fachleute wie die
Informatikerin Hanna Bast sehen
insbesondere in Deutschland einen fast
naiven Umgang mit der neuen Technologie
also in Deutschland erlebe ich immer
wieder ein ausgesprochenen digitalen
Analphabetismus vielen grämien z.B in
der Politik die Sachen entscheiden
bezüglich Technik oder Digitalisierung
gibt es teilweise einen grotesk geringen
Technik Sachverstand das ist ganz
typisch für deutsche Politik und das ist
natürlich eine Katastrophe während
Österreich bereits eigene
Regulierungsmaßnahmen für KI auf den Weg
gebracht hat schauen Deutschland und
auch die Schweiz in diesen Tagen
gespannt nach Brüssel der AI Act von der
EU-Kommission dem EU-Parlament und dem
EU-Rat auf den b soll möglichen
Missbrauch
verhindern wir hatten ein Ziel eine
Gesetzgebung zu erlassen die
sicherstellt dass sich das KI Ökosystem
in Europa mit einem menschenzentrierten
Ansatz entwickelt der die Grundrechte
und die europäischen Werte respektiert
Vertrauen aufbaut und ein Bewusstsein
schafft wie wir das Beste aus dieser KI
Revolution machen können die sich vor
unseren Augen
abspielt schöne Worte die den einen oder
anderen Bösewicht enden Desinformation
und Manipulation bekommt durch
generative KI wie die von Google Gemini
ganz neue Möglichkeiten nicht zuletzt um
Gesellschaften mit Deep Fakes zu
vergiften da beruhigt es auch nicht dass
Google Chef sundai P bei der
Präsentation von Gemini verspricht auch
gleich noch das Gegengift zu
[Musik]
lieferneneremk in die
kantwortungzu geht die togen te erennen
wan immer sie darauf
stoßen Versprechungen die man von den
techkonzernen und Social Media
Betreibern in der Vergangenheit schon
des öfteren
[Musik]
hörte deep Fake Jäger wie Martin
Steinebach sind und bleiben daher
erstmal skeptisch zwar gibt es für
digitalforensiker erste Ansätze deep
Fakes zu erkennen doch es sind nur
Ansätze heutzutage wird manentlich
immer Nation aus einem Computersystem
und einem menschlichen Entscheider
brauchen also ein System alleine schon
Entscheidungen trifft ist das ganze ein
deepfake oder nicht ist das eine
Fälschung oder nicht da ist man noch
weit entfernt hann Bast glaubt daran
dass man in Zukunft die Technologie
regulieren kann doch bis das der Fall
ist wird der jüngste Technologiesprung
wahrscheinlich noch viel
gesellschaftlichen Schaden
anrichten die größte Herausforderung aus
meiner Sicht ist dass das alles gerade
sehr schnell geht sehr viel auf einmal
sehr hohe schlachtzahl und die Leute
nicht mehr mitkommen und das hat einfach
das Potenzial eine Gesellschaft zu
spalten das sehen wir ja jetzt schon
durch soziale Medien zwar räumte Google
vor wenigen Tagen ein dass seine KI
Gemini doch nicht ganz so autonom agiert
wie im präsentationsfilm gezeigt so
wurden Standbilder eingebaut um
Latenzzeiten zu überbrücken doch es wird
immer deutlicher welche Technik rution
gerade
durchstartet was denkst du passiert
jetzt die Katze wird auf den Schrank
springen und sich beim Landen halten das
wird eine perfekte ZH oh das war ein
Fehler es scheint ein bisschen weit weg
zu
sein doch wenn auch noch nicht alles
rundläuft Gemini und Chat GPT lassen
schon jetzt erahnen wie sich unsere Welt
und unser Leben in Zukunft auf der Erde
verändern